what's up guys this is the behind scenes
for our googly eyes video now this is
actually a really unique video basically
we're always in the middle of making
projects but this year we are invited to
speak at a panel just about our channel
at South by Southwest in Austin this
year so we decided what is the coolest
thing we can do we thought why don't we
just make a video from scratch using you
know just the resources we have and try
and make it in only three days because
that's how long we had until the
festival started so because we had to
turn this video around pretty fast we
needed to make it easy to shoot now it'd
be great if you know we could just waltz
into a TV news studio and shoot there
and get away with it but it's
realistically not possible we had to
shoot in our apartment make our
apartment at least kind of look like a
TV studio there's a couple ways to go
about doing that one is the sound design
making sure that your sound makes it
feel like the place is busy but the
other is through lighting and just how
things are staged and what you see on
camera so for example throughout the the
new scenes it's very like it's very
low-key lighting that doesn't feel like
apartment lighting and it's not warm
lighting it's cool lighting which is
kind of more similar to an office
whereas a house tends to have more
tungsten light bulbs it looks a little
bit warmer also we hook our computer
monitors that were in the background and
put just generic news footage on them so
we did have to do any effects but just
makes place look a little more alive a
little more busy we also start the piece
off with Jake walking across camera
talking about the fact that they're
about to run a news story which also
helps set the scene and sell the
environment now to light this piece we
use the LED light panel you can actually
get relatively inexpensive LED panels of
the ebay from users in China who
basically make knockoff LED panels this
one's from the user photo light I would
say 1200 LED panel and it actually is a
v-loc battery mount so we actually use
the batteries we use in our Scarlett
camera to power the light flip it on
lets you pick between daylight and
tungsten and you also have a dimmer that
lets you control the brightness we just
made a point to keep the scene very dark
but have premise like stylistic edge
light basically this lighting the scene
so this light particular pass about four
hundred and fifty dollars the equivalent
light from like light panels is about
two to three grand or something like
that they're very expensive for my
panels but just getting basic like 400
LED 500 LED lights cost like 200 bucks
or so watch out when you're buying stuff
online on
retailers you might get something that's
kind of crappy so it's not a bad idea
check all your reviews make sure they
have a return policy if the lights no
good and other than that just uh make
sure you buy something that suits your
needs so the entire effect is based on
this one technique called
object tracking and basically what I'm
going to be doing is I'm taking a 3d
model that I have and aligning it with
people's faces or the vehicles or
objects whatever and the program is
going to take the geometry from my model
and match it up to my footage so I can
track the position of it basically in
this I have a small little mesh that's
just the front of someone's face near
the eyes and we're using that for all
the face shots I already had that model
leftover from when we did it there's an
alien on your head where you basically
for this car shot I can't use the face
it's not gonna line up I've modeled a
very rough piece that is just like the
hood or part of the hood and the bumper
I don't need a complicated model doesn't
need to be perfect it just needs to be
generally like the right scale and
generally the right shape and usually
the program can do the rest so now that
I'm done modeling I'm going to take it
out of 3ds Max and into PF track first
step is locking the camera off there's
not gonna be any camera movement here
even though there isn't a shot that's a
little janky and it sounds a little
weird but honestly you won't be able to
tell the difference all I'm gonna do is
just line it up as best as I can by eye
and hit track from there so far it's
going you know perfect no no errors it's
kind of weird because I just modeled
this without even looking at the car I
was putting it on and okay second the
last frame there's an error so I'll
tweak that real quick
so one of the challenges with this piece
is we wanted to do physically simulated
googly eyes now there's different
programs that can handle physics
simulations one we looked at was Newton
which does 2d physics simulations and
After Effects we decided to go with 3ds
max so get like the actual correct shine
and stuff on the eyes so anyways we went
into 3ds max started setting it up and
we're getting glitchy results and we
couldn't figure out how to get to work
in a solution to something like this
when you're trying to figure out physics
is to come up with a very simplified
system that represents what you're
eventually going to do so in this case I
created a bowl in a sphere so I used 3d
if max is built in his ex system called
mass effects in this case I simply apply
mass effects to the ball and make it a
dynamic object
I applied mass effects the bowl and I
make that a kinematic object since
that'll be the animated piece the tricky
thing is when you're dealing with
physics systems in the computer it
doesn't handle concave objects very well
like a bowl so physics actually is this
thing built in where it actually takes
it and breaks it down to a bunch of tiny
parts that are all convex parts so it's
just basically you simulate all the
little parts and treat them it's one big
part making the concave shape so in this
case it's just a drop down here they
select that says composite the shape and
it breaks out the bowl into a bunch of
tiny pieces that are all basically
little chunks so when doing googly eyes
basically it's just a slightly different
shape of the googly eye the physics are
basically the same and I have a cylinder
that's just on the back of the google
yea that caps it off so because we had
to turn this video around pretty fast um
in the middle we needed like a news logo
and back when we did sneak we actually
discovered there's this one's website
video hive calm they have a bunch of
great templates and we ended up buying
like a generic news opener template it's
like 30 bucks really sweet animation
like global spinning looks really legit
and so we just use that for the middle
of this video and the guy have made it
basically he has it so ISM everything's
set up and if you want to change any
like the the words or like clips that
would go in there he has all the
compositions set up we just go into
those clips and edit those clips so it's
a super fast way to get something
looking really pro with the help of
somebody else in the preset file that
they've made so that's how we got this
like fancy news opening logo right in
the middle of the piece with only having
to put like 20 minutes of work into it
with a lot of our videos we actually
have this idea like we'll come with an
idea for an effect but you can't just
put an effect on footage it doesn't make
for a good video like people say you
can't have all action scenes and no
story so we always try to come up with a
will structure a little story to kind of
explain what's happening because he put
all this time to an effect but you don't
have any like reason part happening and
the effect is meaningless so we had the
idea that structure and the new went to
town kind of writing an outline a shot
list and then shooting it so we shot
this on Monday I did it Tuesday and we
were on set for vGHS Wednesday and then
Wednesday night we got the eye thing
working in
motion tracking and physics working
today we're doing the rest of the
effects tomorrow we're gonna be on the
plane probably color grading it on our
laptops you're doing sound work Saturday
and Sunday we're going to be at South by
Southwest Monday we're gonna be on the
plane again probably with a hangover and
then on and then Tuesday we'll upload it
so super fast turnaround but uh yeah
not every video has to be a giant
production on all we'll probably put in
about 40 hours meet for about 140 hours
at 7:40 hours it's not too bad other
pieces have been a lot bigger final
thing we're gonna be pulling in the
all-nighters in this one I think came
together really nicely the overwatch is
commanded that we stopped our behind the
scenes now so it must end this video
stream yeah alright guys thanks for
watching behind the scenes hope you
liked it we're going to be releasing the
footage of our panel and discussion at
South by Southwest later this week so
you can see how it went there we talked
a lot about what it's like to run a
YouTube channel for living in the
strategies and things you got to deal
with for that but uh basically what you
guys are privy to every week on yeah
yeah after watching these videos you
know exactly what's going on you know
yeah
you